[Musique]
je veux pas vendre la mèche mais c'est
majordome c'est toujours mieux que
laisse clairement tranquille comme en
dehors
que vous vous faire de l'autre côté de
l'océan c'est mourir un tonneau ce oui
votre mari est mort de fatigue mort de
fatigue
il est en train de dormir monsieur vous
devez regagner votre siège autrement je
devrais appeler la police à luchin on
est déjà mariées depuis 15 ans mais on a
vraiment vraiment été extrêmement
occupés mais toile et dans la foi ça tu
va pas de main morte cette foire et
charles nous invite à passer le week end
en sa compagnie sur son yacht
ça ne me dérange pas de l'incrusté avec
des accords et vous êtes actrice par la
crise valables au
je m'appelle knicks pitt et voici ma
femme alison à cet hôtel
audrey je m'appelle entre audrey a déjà
fait des folies ton corps sur un bateau
soit rallongé et le bateau fantôme
vous pensez qu'il faut l'enlever non ils
mesurent dans les 30 centimes devriez
écouter mon mari il est maintenant vous
savez bien je promets ne leur remettait
pas je me présente inspecteurs laurent
delacroix
je vais vous demander de me suivre pour
un interrogatoire pourquoi sont rompues
mais aussi réussi comment il fait ça
vous l'avez remarqué quelque chose qui
sortait de l'ordinaire
les met où des innocents on est victime
d'une machination
on fait les choses à deux à l'heure s'il
te plaît on peut essayer de résoudre ça
ensemble
cette bourgade avant la bibliothèque ce
qui se passe ils se font tuer tous les
cadavres à la bibliothèque
vous faites la une des journaux ils
disent que vous avez tué quelqu'un tu
crois que c'est possible du comme tu t'y
[Musique]
des tirs de semonce de signature et si
on fait ça il faudra qu'on ait l'air
d'avoir confiance en moi
[Musique]
oh
nairobi testarossa comme son magnum
est ce que tu te rends compte à quel
point ces canaux
je t'aime tu trouves coach métaux